when an off-duty Alaska Airlines pilot
tried to sabotage a passenger plane's
engines in flight this week it took less
than 24 hours for us to learn that the
pilot had recently taken shrooms he was
allegedly High out of his mind when he
attempted to activate the fire
suppression system on the engines
according to officials authorities
released that information for obvious
reasons for one thing you know they
wanted to assure the public that this
incident was not part of some broader
terrorist plot given the events in the
Middle East and more importantly the
authorities understood that they needed
to provide some kind of explanation for
why an Alaska Airlines pilot would
decide out of the blue to try to kill 83
passengers on one of his company's
planes after all when a senseless act of
attempted mass murder happens the news
media and the American public uh are
usually very interested in the details
they want to know for example what drugs
were in the system of the wouldbe Killer
and in the case of the Alaska pilot
those details were provided right away
uh even in an incident in this case
where nobody died we got some
transparency and we got it immediately
as should be the case and all that makes
sense what doesn't make sense by
contrast is how the media has reported
on Robert card The 40-Year-Old petroleum
specialist in the US Army Reserve who
according to authorities just went on a
shooting rampage in Maine card allegedly
killed 18 people at a bowling alley and
a bar he wounded many others and here's
how various news organizations described
card's potential motivations watch we
have more breaking news regarding the
mental health history of the man
suspected of killing 18 people in Maine
I want to bring in kend delanian NBC
News justice and intelligence
correspondent Ken what have you just
learned Chris it's become increasingly
clear that there were major concerns
about this suspect Robert card's mental
health over the summer and as recently
as a few weeks ago both from his
military commanders and members of his
family I've got two pieces of
information to share with you two senior
law enforcement officials tell me that
card's Army Reserve Commanders referred
him to inpatient psychiatric treatment
over the summer after they be became
concerned about his comments that he had
been hearing voices and about threats
that he had made to the base and we're
told that he spent about two weeks
inside a psychiatric facility was
treated there was released it's unclear
what happened after that he's a Firearms
instructor and is known to have mental
health issues particularly had reported
hearing voices in his head had
previously threatened to shoot up
a military base before and as recently
as this summer spent 2 weeks in a mental
health facility then was released now
those details there are going to raise
all sorts of questions in red flags as
to how he's got that rifle that he's
holding in these photos right now with
those kind of mental health issues going
into a mental health facility this
summer uh there going to be all sorts of
questions asked as to how this guy was
able to possess a firearm like that if
we look at the suspect Robert card
certified Firearms instructor member of
the US Army Reserve made threats to
carry out a shooting at National Guard
facility earlier on according to
authorities and Reporting mental health
issues including hearing voices if you
look at all of that you combine it with
that information you just reported there
the idea that this is somebody who may
know the outdoors very well who may be
very skilled at this you understand how
this shooting this really changes the
approach that law enforcement has to
take to him so Robert card all these new
news outlets tell us suffered from
serious mental health problems there
were major concerns he was impatient at
a psychiatric facility just the summer
for at least two weeks everyone from his
military commanders to his family knew
about this and therefore these Outlets
all of them including Fox CNN MSNBC have
the same question such as um how was he
able to access Firearms the laws in
place are already supposed to prevent
somebody like card from having guns so
why weren't those laws followed or
enforced and those are very good
questions they need to be answered we
also need to know why Robert card was
ever released from that impatient
psychiatric facility especially when the
US military apparently knew that he
wanted to shoot up the base several
commentators have raised that question
as well but there's another question
that is important to ask which none of
these media Outlets have been talking
about it's the same question that the
media answered very quickly in the case
of the Alaska Airlines pilot which is
what drugs exactly
were in the shooter system and along
those same lines what drugs has he been
taking recently so if he was hearing
voices in his head and talking about
suicide there's a good chance that he
was on antipsychotic medication he might
have been on ssris as well could those
drugs have made him even more violent
than he already was these are questions
that most of the national news media
actively discourage you from asking
you're called a conspiracy theorist if
you try to bring up this topic
in fact you'll probably be censored on
major social media platforms earlier
this year for example USA Today ran a
fact check claiming that
anti-depressants are not linked to
school shootings and if you try to claim
otherwise on Facebook there's a good
chance that USA today's fact check will
appear alongside your post so what's the
evidence that anti-depressants are not
in fact linked to school shootings well
as part of this fact check usat linked
to a study from Columbia University on
mass shootings and here's what the study
found quote we identified 1,000 35 mass
murders 65% of which involve Firearms
lifetime psychotic symptoms were noted
among 11% of perpetrators these results
suggest that policies aimed at
preventing mass shootings by focusing on
serious mental illness characterized by
psychotic symptoms may have limited
impact now if you just read those
statistics and accept the framing of USA
Today in Columbia University they're
pretty convincing you might come away
with the idea that psychoactive drugs
can't possibly be causing mass shooting
since only 11% of the perpetrators have
lifetime psychotic symptoms therefore
you know there's a good chance that many
of them are not taking ssris and other
medications but if you read the fine
print you might notice something that
explains these figures here's how
Columbia defines a mass shooting quote
the unlawful killing of four or more
individuals excluding the perpetrators
within one event in one
location in other words gang violence
counts drive by shootings targeting
rival drug dealers count
Etc so what we're seeing here is a
statistical slight of hand you know of
course we should be doing everything we
possibly can to stop mass shootings as
Columbia University defines them we
should enforce laws that are already on
the books we should stop releasing
criminals as soon as they're arrested um
at the same time the fact that all these
mass shootings are occurring in the
absence of ssris doesn't tell us
anything whatsoever about the role of
psychoactive drugs in causing violent
Behavior Colombia's researchers don't
address the core question how many
people who aren't gangbangers who aren't
career criminals are taking
ssris and then going on to commit mass
shootings that they would not have
committed
otherwise now not too long ago some Medi
Outlets were willing to Broach that
question here's the BBC for example in a
report that aired 7 years ago watch I
was an
absolute mess wanting to take my life
like
continually
[Music]
I got I read the leaflet and I was
getting exactly what it said you know I
was getting kind of seizure like
symptoms where um my muscles were kind
of jolting around of their own accord
and I felt disorientated and sick and
had digestive problems and infections
and I me it's really really
extreme
one and four people become more anxious
rather than less and they can become
extraordinarily anxious so that some
people become very agitated and some go
on from that to become
suicidal okay so roughly a quarter of
people taking these drugs according to
that report are actually experiencing
increased agitation it's not just that
the drug failed to solve their problem
the drug actively made their problem
worse now none of this is really a
revelation if you look at the labels on
these drugs you'll often find that drug
companies come right out and admit it so
here's the label of Prozac word for word
quote all patients being treated with
anti-depressants for any indication
should be um monitored appropriately and
observed closely for clinical worsening
suicidality and unusual changes in
Behavior the following symptoms anxiety
agitation panic attacks insomnia
irritability hostility aggressiveness
impulsivity and Mania have been reported
in adult and pediatric patients being
treated with anti-depressants for major
depressive disorder as well as for other
indications the label goes on to say
that no causal link has been established
between these symptoms and the drug but
it obviously doesn't rule it out that's
why they put it on the
label okay and if you look at recent
mass shootings going going back for the
past few decades you begin to see why
they put it on the label
anti-depressants as well as other
psychoactive drugs have been a common
denominator in many of these
killings too many to even
count but we'll recount a few of them
Eric Harris one of the Coline Shooters
was taking two separate ssris uh Zoloft
and louo Kip Kinkle who murdered his
parents before shooting 25 of his
classmates killing two of them was
taking Prozac which is another
SSRI Jeff Weiss the 16-year-old had
murdered nine people in Minnesota
including his grandfather before killing
himself was on Prozac one of his family
members told the New York Times quote
they kept upping the dose for him and by
the end he was taking three of the 20
milligram pills a day I can't help but
think it was too much that it must have
set him off another relative said quote
I do wonder whether on top of everything
else he had going on in his life on top
of all the other problems whether the
drugs could have been the final straw a
27-year-old who killed six people at
Northern Illinois University in 2008 was
reportedly on Prozac as well so was
Joseph West West Becker in 1989 he
killed eight co-workers at a printing
plan in Kentucky while taking the
anti-depressant in 2001 Christopher
Pitman was taking zolof when he killed
his grandparents and at trial his
lawyers blamed the drug Kenneth sn's
lawyers uh made a similar argument he
brutally murdered his wife and two
children after his doctor prescribed him
Prozac now I could go on and on and list
dozens of other examples the Navy Yard
shooter in 2013 Aaron Alex Alexis was uh
was on anti-depressants James Holmes who
shot 82 people in that movie theater in
Aurora Colorado was on Zoloft Dylan rof
the white supremacist Church shooter was
on ssris as well um the trans identified
shooter who killed men women and
children at the Christian School in
Tennessee this year was under care for a
quote emotional disorder but you're not
allowed to know any details about that
you're also not allowed to read the
Killer's Manifesto in that case a couple
of months ago a mental health Watchdog
called the citizens Commission on human
rights pointed out that the mass shooter
at a Kentucky Bank who killed five
people and wounded many others was
taking medication for depression the
group called for an investigation into
possible links between psychoactive
drugs and and quote senseless
violence but no investigation would be
forthcoming of course corporate media
organizations have no incentive to
undertake any kind of Investigation like
that because they make hundreds of
millions of dollars a year from Big
Pharma and honestly they may not be the
only ones who are being paid off nobody
ever talks about this but a couple of
years ago it emerged that Eli Lily which
makes Prozac was accused of of uh paying
money to the victims of a mass shooting
in order to protect their brand quoting
from the USA Today uh quote the drug
maker that produces Prozac the
anti-depressant that Joseph West
Becker's victims blame for his deadly
shooting rampage 30 years ago secretly
paid the victims $20 million to help
ensure a verdict exonerating The Drug
Company Indianapolis based Eli Lily
vigorously shielded the payments for
more than two decades defying a
Louisville judge who fought to reveal it
because he said it swayed the jury's
verdict now was there a link between
Prozac and that deadly Rampage we can't
say seems like the company was worried
that there might be we do know two
things for sure first the most powerful
forces in media and big Pharma do not
want you to ask these kinds of
questions and second we know that a lot
of people who are taking these drugs are
killing people in ways that are utterly
horrifying these are not just Mass
Shooters either the daily wire just
reported on the case of a Massachusetts
mother who methodically strangled her
three children including a 5-year-old a
three-year-old and an eight month old uh
to death before trying to kill herself
she took four minutes to complete each
Murder She strangled each of them with
an exercise band and she cut her own
throat and jumped out the window now
according to the women's woman's lawyers
uh she quote suffer from postpartum
depression and was overprescribed
medicine
now this is the kind of crime that
demands an
explanation why in God's name would a
mother seemingly normal and law- abiding
until that moment suddenly decide to
methodically murder all of her children
postpartum depression is not an
explanation that's what the media has
been telling oh she has postpartum
depression okay lots of women get
postpartum depression almost none of
them have ever done or would ever do
something like that this mother did why
we need to know
why at this point inevitably some people
will point out that correlation is not
causation that's true you know the fact
that a bunch of people on ssris and
Other Drugs like Ridin are committing
mass killings does not necessarily prove
that these drugs are causing those
killings but it certainly suggests that
it's a
possibility the drug makers themselves
acknowledge that it's a
possibility and every effort to debunk
this hypothesis has been misleading at
best and fraudulent at
worst drug makers are being accused of
paying off victims corporate media
Outlets are burying the statistics by
citing gang killings meanwhile the
bodies are piling
up you know as much as leftist dream of
solving this problem by seizing all the
guns and jailing everybody who believes
in the Second Amendment that's not going
to happen I mean there would be
Bloodshed on a scale never seen before
in human history if the government
attempted anything like that so there's
really only one option that could
potentially save lives instead of
bringing down the entirety of our
constitutional republic and that option
is to determine
conclusively why mass shootings and
suicides are becom BEC more common over
the past few decades during which SSR
SSRI use has soared by roughly
3,000% it was just a couple of years ago
that the pharmaceutical industry
admitted that it has no idea how these
ssris are even supposed to work their
basis for prescribing them the chemical
imbalance in the brain bit that was a
myth and that has been
admitted so so what that means is that
the people giving these drugs to people
they don't even know exactly how they
work or why they work or if they
do so you would think that everybody
would welcome an investigation into
this if you have these drugs that more
and more people are taking and at the
same time more and more violent uh
heinous crimes like these are being
committed you would think that lots of
people would be asking questions but
right now no one seemingly is asking the
question they're just talking about new
laws to take away people guns even
though Maine already had a so-called
yellow flag law that should have ensured
Robert card didn't have access to
Firearms but he did they're offering
non-solutions that will expand their
power while limiting your rights they're
confident about their ideas even though
none of them has done anything to stop
mass shooting since
Coline they only become more
common so maybe it's time for a new
approach maybe it's time for the one
solution they don't want you to talk
about which is investigating what role
psychoactive drugs are playing in these
killings now I don't know what that
investigation might
find all I know is that as more and more
people are put on the psychotropic drugs
we seem to end up with more and more
psychotic Mass killers at a minimum this
would indicate it would seem that the
drugs are not effective in stopping
these tragedies from
occurring best case for the drug makers
is that they're pushing an ineffective
product worst case and a very plausible
case is that they're pushing something
that is actively contributing to the
very thing it's supposed to
prevent we don't know for sure because
very few people are interested in
finding
out what I do know is that if any real
investigation ever took place then big
Pharma and its media clients would stand
to lose a lot of
money and for that reason there will be
no
investigation instead there will be a
lot more Robert cards and Dy and Dylan
roofs and Kip kinkl
and when you tune in to the NFL or Fox
News or CNN you'll continue to be
bombarded with advertisements from the
companies that were prescribing those
Killers their
medications the media will continue to
make money on both ends they get the
ratings from their breaking coverage of
mass shootings and they get the ad
dollars from big
farma and unfortunately for people in
bowling alleys and bars and schools all
over the country the cycle will
continue if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed